from
epic battle scenes impenetrable costumes
and impossible stunts marvel
constantly has their fans jaws dropping
with 98
of the footage from the mcu films being
sent to the special
effects editing professionals it isn't
hard to imagine
how different our favorite avengers look
behind the scenes
but imagining and seeing are two
different things from end game to
wandavision and peter parker in between
you won't believe how dramatically
different these marvel scenes look
without the power of vfx and cgi
just a big chocolate missile how iconic
was this girl power moment in avengers
end game
however while it may have come together
seamlessly on screen
the arrival of the female avengers took
a bit more extra work behind the scenes
as you can see here each avenger had to
be added in
almost one by one some of them were
included using special effects
and others just popped up from
underneath the camera's view
you got something for me captain
america's encounter with himself while
searching for the infinity stones was
already
mind-boggling but watching how they
filmed the scene
hurt our brains even more chris evans
filmed both parts individually with his
stunt double swapping roles between
takes the editors did their magic later
on to make it seem as if it truly was
a double trouble situation
i can do this all day yeah i know
although heartbreaking
watching tony stark's sacrifice again is
worth it just to see how it looked
behind the scenes
there was actually no infinity glove no
battle raging around him
and no thanos looming over him just
rdj's pure talent
this vision versus vision fight in wanda
vision took
a lot of work paul bettany filmed this
scene with his stunt double and they
later digitally enhanced his stunt
doubles face to look like paul instead
you can also see that the upper part of
vision's suit as well as the environment
around them
was added in later with special effects
but i'm not the true vision
getting to see the true strength of
wanda's powers in wanda vision was
epic but the cast and crew weren't
treated to the same experience while
elizabeth olsen was filming without
special effects wanda's combustion in
the west view town square
kinda looked a little like an adult
temper tantrum but it's still
impressive to think about how it all
came together in the end
this scene had our heart rates spiking
but we're glad to know tom holland
wasn't in any danger filming it behind
the scenes thanos's ship was actually
just a green screen wall that tom
holland was climbing while attached to a
wire
and wearing a motion capture suit we're
too high up you're running out of air
that makes sense the final battle was
much less anticlimactic behind the
scenes than on screen
the majority of the time the cast wasn't
even on set with one another at the same
time
the day where the avengers charged was
when they had the most people on set and
even that pales in comparison to all the
digital enemies we saw in the final cut
if you look closely
you'll see the avenger army charged into
a green screen
filming black widow and her motorcycle
was an event
that included a harley bike specifically
created for the film
stunt doubles and motorcycle cameras for
close-up shots they would film scarlett
johansson at a standstill but for action
shocks they had her stunt double weaving
in and out of cars while two cameras
followed in front and behind on
motorcycles of their own
can we always pick it up after you boys
not all special effects are done with
vfx especially in the first episodes of
wandavision
they swapped out wanda's red waves of
power for strings poles and simple speed
adjustments to achieve that perfect
1950s style well please eat before it
gets cold
sorry to disappoint but thanos not real
not even behind the scenes in order to
bring him to life
josh brolin had to wear a big motion
capture suit which made his battle for
the infinity gauntlet with captain
america in
end game a little awkward without all of
the special effects
captain america's shield was also added
with vfx meaning while filming it was
basically chris evans throwing an
imaginary weapon at josh brolin
while he pretended to get hit all six
stones i could simply
snap my fingers living on a land full of
vibranium would be
epic but unfortunately wakanda was all
green screen and special effects
including their futuristic planes
however they still tried to make filming
as realistic as possible
like the fight scene between t'challa
and umbaku where the set designer
created a pretty realistic base for the
shoot
glory to hanuman dr strange's cape for a
lot of the scenes wasn't
actually there benedict cumberbatch
would go through the motions of grabbing
and putting on the cape
but it was added in later on using
special effects they just couldn't
recreate how life-like it was without
help from the digital realm
however in other scenes where it wasn't
the main focus it was just a part of
benedict's costume
mark ruffalo has expressed in the past
how embarrassing it sometimes was to be
dressed in a large motion capture suit
around the rest of the avengers cast
while we admit it looks a bit odd it was
also that the editing team could do
their magic like in
this scene with the hulk and the ancient
one he's wearing his suit but also
standing on an elevated surface
in a green screen studio instead of new
york
and hulk
smash it's obvious to see that the
spider-man
illusion battle was completely done
using digital effects thanks to the
company
frame store however how did they get
spider-man to move so much like tom
holland
well they made sure that they filmed the
stunts and movements with tom in a
motion capture suit so that they'd be
able to add the extra realism to the
scene
zendaya's part was also added into the
digital sequence
later on we saw plenty of different
versions of vision in wandavision
however
what we didn't realize is that for a
portion of the series
he was actually blue avatar blue the
showrunners worked with the makeup
department to find what color paint
would look the best
translated in black and white turns out
blue looked much better than maroon and
they stuck with the color through every
black and white scene he shot
humans are odd valkyrie's entrance was
intense but when you take a peek behind
the curtains the intensity is
deflated the horse she was riding was
actually just an
animatronic and the area around her was
completely green screen
even wanda's magical drop down was done
with just elizabeth olsen and a harness
as much as we wish these portals were
real those magic rings we see in doctor
strange are actually
just shiny metal circles with a green
screen backdrop
they were elevated to give the effects
of the actors stepping in
and did help them meet their marks
evidently adding a little more realism
to it all
hi everyone i hope you're enjoying this
film to get captain marvel in the air
involved
a lot of vfx green screen and major
dedication from brie larson the actress
was attached to a contraption made of
poles that allowed the film crew to
rotate her and manipulate her in any
direction they needed
this was all done in front of a green
screen so that her powers
location and even part of her suit could
be added in during post-production
it takes a lot to make a superhero look
fabulous
the spider-man cast didn't actually film
in london
at least for this battle scene and far
from home the vfx team created
a digital london for the film while the
actors performed in a studio with
minimal props and structures compared to
what we see in the final cut
sorry to break the illusion but iron
man's suit wasn't
actually physically there the majority
of the time oftentimes
rdj would just wear part of the armor on
top of a motion capture suit there were
other scenes where he would wear a
physically
larger suit with his helmet being the
only part added with vfx
it really depended on what the script
required of him that day
is everything a joke to you funny things
the marvel creators got to spend extra
time playing around with falcon for his
new series
falcon and the winter soldier and we
aren't complaining
they put in the work researching and
using footage from skydivers in order to
get the perfect look for the falcons
flying scenes
they seamlessly fit together raw shots
and digital creations to give us these
shots
getting chris evans to look a lot
smaller than he really was
was a challenge the production team had
to go through multiple steps
first the scene was filmed with body
double leander dini who still had to
diet for the role
they then digitally replaced his face
with chris evans in editing
sometimes they would even have to scale
down the actor compared to the
environment
depending on the scene iron man wasn't
the only one with cool gadgets at his
expense
we got to see happy's plane in
spider-man far from home and we were
just as impressed as peter parker
however behind the scenes the plane
didn't really exist
while they did build part of the
interior as a set the majority was
created digitally
watching how they filmed the rocket
raccoon scenes is kind of
unsettling take a look rocket was of
course created digitally but in order to
capture realistic movements
sean gunn the director's brother acted
out the scenes in a motion capture suit
because of the animal-like movements he
was able to replicate
the vulture wasn't slick and fast which
means the spider-man filmmakers needed
to make sure the vulture's special
effects portrayed his heaviness it
required some research on how humans
look
flying with jet packs so that they could
replicate it and
then add in those digitally created
wings
is an intense look no wonder it seems
like marvel takes forever to release
their new projects
it's because a lot of editing and
behind-the-scenes work
goes into making these mcu scenes top
tier
and we aren't complaining what scenes
were you most shocked
to see without special effects thanks
for watching